Bonjour à tous et à toutes et joyeuses fêtes !!
Et oui, on n'a pas résisté à vous faire
un petit épisode de noël !
(entre nous c'est surtout parce que toute l'équipe adore porter des bonnets ridicules)
On a concocté un épisode qui devrait vous plaire,
surtout à toi Benoît !
oui toi, Benoît, qui partage beaucoup nos vidéos
et qui travaille à la production d'un certain vin pétillant...
Alors non, non, je ne vais pas vous faire un épisode sur la science des bulles de champagne.
On a déjà assez parlé de bulles dans l'épisode sur la mousse de la bière.
Vous vous souvenez?
Non, aujourd'hui on débouche le champagne
et on fait des panaches bleus !
Cette vidéo a été tournée à 8000 images par seconde
par l'équipe Effervescence de l'Université de Reims.
Lorsque le bouchon est éjecté, un étrange panache azur est visible au niveau du goulot
Ne vous jetez pas sur vos bouteilles de champagne pour tester !
D'une part, le phénomène se déroule dans les 2 premières milisecondes de l'ouverture,
et d'autre part, il faut que votre bouteille soit à plus de 12°C.
Pas idéal pour un champagne...
D'un point de vue purement chimique, le champagne est simplement
une solution hydroalcoolique contenant du dioxyde de carbone dissous
formé pendant la phase appelée "prise de mousse" par les connaisseurs.
On a de l'eau, de l'alcool et des bulles quoi...
Et quelques molécules pour donner du gout... OK.
Lorsqu'on ouvre une bouteille de champagne, le petit nuage de gaz présents dans le goulot
(du CO2 et quelques traces de vapeur d'eau)
va sortir et se dilater.
Ce gaz carbonique qui était soumis à une très forte pression,
va passer à la pression de l'air ambiant en moins de 3 milisecondes !
Cette diminution brutale de la pression du CO2
entraîne une diminution tout aussi brutale de sa température.
On va voir 2 cas de figure :
sur ces images, la bouteille a été conservé à une température inférieure à 12°C.
On peut voir un petit nuage blanc-gris
qui correspond à la condensation de la vapeur d'eau
naturellement présente dans l'air autour de la bouteille.
Comme les nuages dans le ciel !
Sur ses autres images,
on voit l'ouverture d'une bouteille qui elle, est conservée à 20°C.
Et là, pas de nuage blanc,
mais un étonnant panache bleu, bien vertical.
Les chercheurs ont déterminé que ce panache bleu est dû, en fait,
à un nuage de microparticules de neige carbonique
qui va diffuser la lumière.
...et ouais, c'est du CO2 congelé,
dans votre bouteille de champagne.
Pourtant le CO2 ne se congèle qu'à -78°C...
Ce qu'il faut savoir,
c'est qu'à l'ouverture de cette bouteille,
la température du gaz va chuter de plus de 100°C en l'espace de 3 milisecondes,
atteignant jusqu'à -88°C.
Le point de congélation du CO2 est alors franchi,
et de minuscules cristaux de glace carbonique vont alors se former
sans passer par la phase liquide !
Et ce sont ces minuscules cristaux de glace carbonique
qui sont responsables de la couleur bleue du panache.
Le bleu du ciel est dû au même phénomène...
Ca s'appelle la diffusion de Rayleigh.
Mais pourquoi le panache bleu
ne se forme qu'avec une bouteille
qui est conservé à une température de plus de 12°C ?
Plus la bouteille est chaude, plus il y a de
CO2 sous forme de gaz dans le goulot
et moins il ya de CO2 dans le liquide.
...exactement comme quand on laisse une bouteille de soda en dehors du frigo.
La pression du gaz dans le goulot de cette bouteille est donc plus grande au départ,
et à l'ouverture, la décompression
va donc être plus forte
et la chute de température plus importante !
Et paf ! ça fait des micros glaçons de CO2 !!
Allez c'est cadeau :
voilà à quoi ressemble le jet de liquide
au moment de l'ouverture d'une bouteille,
filmé à 8000 images par seconde...
Pourquoi cette couleur cuivrée ?
eh bien tout simplement parce que pour cette étude
(publiée dans la revue Nature d'ailleurs)
les chercheurs ont utilisé des bouteilles transparentes...
...de champagne rosé !
Bon, de mon côté, je vais mettre les bouteilles bien au frais en attendant le nouvel an.
Je vous souhaite de très bonnes fêtes de fin d'année,
Et, comme le CO2...
décompressez !